well it's bringing more than that
breaking news in the past 15 minutes or
thereabout so it seems now all that's
certain that the 2020 Olympics in Japan
will be postponed to Japanese Prime
Minister Shinzo Abe a has said in the
past few minutes that the International
Olympic Committee's president Thomas
Bach has agreed to a proposal of a
postponement for about a year skies
Rebecca Williams joins us from the
newsroom
Rebecca to some degree this was starting
to feel inevitable wasn't it the
Canadians and in particularly Australian
said they would have nothing to do with
the 2020 Olympics yeah last week they
said that they wouldn't send teams to
the Olympics and so pressure was
certainly mounting on the International
Olympic Committee to make a decision
they have said for months now that it
would go ahead on the 24th of July as
planned 11,000 athletes from all over
the world were due to attend the
Olympics in Tokyo and now they have made
this decision it seems that it will
instead be held next summer it's going
to be postponed and that is really
really significant they've only been
three cancellations of an Olympics in
modern history and that was down to the
First World War and the Second World War
now obviously the spread of coronavirus
is the primary focus here the health of
the athletes of fans heading out there
and so clearly this decision has been
made it was a request as you say from
the Japanese Prime Minister Shinzo Abe a
who called for it to be postponed until
next summer we're also hearing now from
the Olympics Minister that that
postponement won't go on past next
summer so it seems inevitable that it
will be one years postponement this was
all decided this afternoon on a
conference call between the IOC the
Japanese government and the organising
committee and like you say a number of
governing bodies have started to pile on
the pressure so we heard that the
Australian team wouldn't attend that the
Canadians wouldn't attend and certainly
the British Olympic Association were in
favor of this postponement we started to
hear from athletes as well who said that
they were unable to train the whole
point of the Olympic Games is that
everyone starts on a level playing field
they all get the equal amount of
training and certainly were countries
and look down over the coronavirus we've
heard that they have found that very
difficult we heard from the heptathlon
Katarina Johnson Thompson last week she
said she was trust
to train in Montpellier which is where
she's based in France we've also heard
from Dena Asha Smith who courses one of
the key hopefuls for Team GB in this
Olympics and she says she was having to
balance the priority of training and
keeping her family safe and I
interviewed at the swimmer Adam PT a
couple of weeks ago and he said the
postponement was the most likely option
he said competing behind closed doors
would be incredibly difficult because
it's very hard for athletes to motivate
themselves but yet it now seems
2020 Olympic Games in Tokyo has been
postponed and it will instead be held
next summer hopefully a time for
everyone to get together when the
coronavirus you would hope has subsided
and that threat is now over and people
can celebrate